one of the great questions that starts
being answered perhaps here at Summer
League here's Jabari Smith nice little
finger roll smooth in doing it 3 16 to
go here in the third quarter this is the
first of two tonight Smith got it
a special shooter saying if you can play
we'll find you a guy who played a
division two it was just a winner flat
out winner there are guys that emerge I
mean think about Miami-Dade Vincent one
for nine here in the first half and 0
for five from distance he is struggling
obviously
Holmgren against Smith defends him
nicely on that spin move in the low box
that's on everything but make shots he's
rebounded the ball he's defended now
he's gonna knock down that jumper
deflects it again
Jalen Williams shot not there Jabari
Smith able to get a hand up
[Applause]
by the Thunder I think for for most
great players if they're having an off
tonight they're always looking for
something
the defense there by Smith Jacobs
sliding his feet against Wesley who
we've seen can get by people yeah little
little leak out
high top Washington with a Miss Switzer
and Juan Jabari Smith
Jabari Smith this is this is a mark of a
great player by the way it is yes light
came on for me my senior year
I'm serious Stephanie probably more
being more realistic my junior year
right right and see he understands he
got a smaller guy he look don't throw a
big guy bounce back right I hate that
one-handed Jam yeah
it's gonna be a fun season and and what
people know I'm saying young coaches you
grow as a coach from year to year you
learn things you get better at things
and so oh
Jabari first yep
52 seconds remaining
Jabari Smith Jr spin move I love that
two points yo the top three picks I've
been impressed with all of them they all
can flat out and play
that's a heck of a move right here spin
move now he started his dribble
obviously I do I've been doing the draft
in-house show Stephanie you and I've
done that show at Barclays I haven't I
can't recall last time we've seen a
young man you know just climb the draft
board from late first round the top ten
and then what going four
now we're going to get to see him do his
thing
yeah
dunk was pretty
and another attempt
whoa
yeah normally in the regular season I
say get that shot out of here in 3D what
I love about that block he retained
possessions I I tell guys big guys it's
one thing to knock it in the third